في هذه الأثناء، تزعم كل من روسيا وأوكرانيا أن
الأخرى شنت
هجمات ضخمة داخل أراضيها بين عشية وضحاها،
ويقول المسؤولون الروس إن ثلاث طائرات بدون طيار
أسقطت في منطقة بريانسك، وهو
انفجار كبير، وفي وقت مبكر من
صباح الأربعاء، شهدت روسيا أكبر
هجوم بطائرة بدون طيار على أراضيها منذ أن
أطلقت عملياتها العسكرية.  الحرب في أوكرانيا
في هذه الأثناء ضربت روسيا كييف
بقصف هائل، كما يقول أكبر المسؤولين
منذ الربيع. سيينا ليس البشير
يتابع القصة من لندن لا
أريد أن أبدأ بهجمات الطائرات بدون طيار
داخل روسيا، ما هو الأحدث
هناك،
انظر جيدًا  "لقد شهدنا بالتأكيد
ارتفاعًا طفيفًا خلال الأسابيع الأخيرة في هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار
على الأراضي الروسية كما
ذكرت أنه هذا الصباح فقط
تمت محاولة هجوم أخرى بطائرات بدون طيار وفقًا
للسلطات المحلية التي تستهدف موسكو
العاصمة في روسيا وبالطبع كما
ذكرت هناك تم إطلاق النار على ثلاث طائرات بدون طيار أخرى
في
المنطقة الروسية بفرنسا الآن تقول السلطات الروسية إن
دفاعاتها الجوية
نجحت في إحباط هذه الهجمات
ولكن كما ذكرت أن هذا يأتي بعد
يوم واحد فقط من أكبر
هجوم بطائرات بدون طيار شهدناه على الأراضي الروسية
منذ بداية الحرب الآن
بالطبع من المهم ملاحظة أن
السلطات الأوكرانية عادة لا
تعترف أو تعترف بمسؤوليتها عن
مثل هذه الهجمات، وفي الواقع سمعنا من أحد
مستشاري المكتب الرئاسي
يقول إن أوكرانيا تلتزم
بأوامرها الصارمة بعدم استخدام مثل هذه الأسلحة التي
يقدمها شركاؤها.  ضد
الأراضي الروسية ولكن إذا شهدنا
زيادة حادة في هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار، فقد
أصبح هذا عنصرًا رئيسيًا في المياه في
روسيا وأنت ملكة بالطبع، فقد رأينا
مناطق متعددة مستهدفة يوم الأربعاء
بهجمات الطائرات بدون طيار مما تسبب في بعض
الأضرار في البنية التحتية التي رأيناها على الأقل  تعرضت
أربع طائرات عسكرية
لأضرار نتيجة لهذه
الهجمات بطائرات بدون طيار، مما اضطر العديد من المطارات في روسيا
إلى الإغلاق مؤقتًا، لذلك كان لذلك
تأثير، وقد سمعنا في
الماضي من السلطات الأوكرانية مرة أخرى،
بينما لم تعترف بشكل مباشر
بالمسؤولية عن مثل هذه الهجمات بطائرات بدون طيار، كما
قالوا.  أنهم سيستمرون
في رؤية زيادة في حجم ونطاق
مثل هذه الهجمات طالما
بقيت القوات الروسية على الأراضي الأوكرانية وفي
المياه الأوكرانية وبالطبع
سمعنا من مستشار الرئيس
الذي قال إن الحرب مستمرة.
التحرك بشكل متزايد نحو
الأراضي الروسية، أصبح هذا عاملاً رئيسياً
ضمن التحذير بالطبع مع تزايد
استخدام
السلطات الأوكرانية للطائرات بدون طيار، فمن المحتمل أن نشهد
المزيد من الهجمات ضد الأراضي الروسية